ja recht gesund und schaue immer was wir
alles essen und verzehren alles schön
Bio soweit es eben auch geht auch bei
den Kindern und was immer auch ganz
wichtig ist dass eben nicht nur das was
wir essen wichtig ist für den Körper
sondern auch das was auf die Haut drauf
kommt denn die Haut das ist müsst ihr
auch wissen einfach unser größtes Organ
und alles was auf die Haut kommt kommt
praktisch in den Körper mit rein und
deswegen haben wir eine Creme entwickelt
die quasi aus Naturkosmetik besteht die
aus Zutaten besteht die man wirklich
auch essen kann das zeige ich euch
später auch da sind wir auf die Idee
gekommen weil wir uns gedacht haben wir
könnten doch unser Rosenöl unser
Rosenwasser verbinden mit unserem
Olivenöl was eben auch richtig toll für
die Haut ist und haben dann gedacht dass
wir nicht nur Rose verwenden sondern
eben auch orange hoch seht ihr jetzt
kommt der schon eine ganze Wind eben
auch orange und auch Lavendel
[Musik]